ich glaube es ja nicht kann es denn
wirklich sein ist das etwa neo oder
hallo leute hier wäre mal von und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt's einer neuen alten folge denn
wir machen heute wieder den kuchen aus
schneewittchen fun fact das war mein
allererstes wie schmeckt's video weit
davon weg alles in dem video bei nicht
falsch also willkommen zu ich hätte mein
eigenes erstes wie schmeckt's video mein
allererstes wie schmeckt's video kam am
16 oktober
2016 raus hallo leute ich ist wieder
einmal wanne das war vor 55 jahren seit
fünf jahren gibt es dieses format ich
bin ziemlich aufgeregt denn ich habe mir
ein format überlegt was ich ziemlich
cool finde was ab heute starten wird und
nein ich werde nicht holzfällen obwohl
die rechte dafür angezogen bin es ist
fünf jahre her ich war ein bisschen
komisch diese kirche ist man kitsch und
warum hätte ich denn jetzt mein eigenes
wie schmeckt video das liegt daran dass
ich einen großen fehler gemacht habe und
zwar habe ich äpfel stadt stachelbeeren
benutzt ich war mir damals super sicher
dass apple sein müssen aber
das kostüm ist ein bisschen sorry aber
in den kommentaren wurde mehrfach gesagt
dass das nicht stimmt zum beispiel also
sagen kann geschrieben vor vier jahren
eigentlich hatten die mädchen
stachelbeere kompott gemacht und bekam
von der bösen königin den vorschlag
lieber apfelkuchen zu backen tja ich
würde mal sagen verkackt ich muss auf
jeden fall wissen wie der original
schädigungen schmeckt und nicht meine
billige abgeklatscht nicht mal echte
version von vor fünf jahren sonst kann
ich keine nacht mehr ruhig schlafen
kommen wir zu den zutaten als ich damals
die zutaten zusammengestellt haben habe
ich einfach einen fehler nach dem
anderen gemacht jetzt sachen behauptet
die überhaupt keine grundlage hatten und
zwar habe ich gesagt dass sie damals
wahrscheinlich nur vollkornmehl hatten
weil so das mittelalter war also in
schneewittchen zeiten
das stimmt aber anscheinend nicht sie
hatten wohl auch normales mail also
benutzen wir heute eine mischung aus
normalem mehl und vollkommen die an der
mutter hat sich nichts verändert
butterweich mutter dann brauchen wir
noch ein ei zucker und da bin ich mir
jetzt auch nicht so sicher ob es denn
schon so gegeben hatte mittelalter so
wie wir ihn heute benutzen aber wir sind
wir nehmen einfach mal zucker damit der
starnberg guten auch ein starren wer
kuchen werden kann stahl bären frisch
aus dem wald gepflückt das war der
ursprungsplan wir wollten das video
eigentlich drehen als stachel der saison
war dann ist aber meine psyche
dazwischen gekommen und wir mussten
pause machen deswegen konnte ich keine
stachelbeeren mehr finden und haptik
staffel werden gekauft es ist aber eine
ahnung diesen super fresh aus und gut
und ich glaube das wird
und nun kommen wir zur zubereitung was
ich 2016 noch nicht hatte das leblos auf
meinem des krieges wie so eine werbung
einstieg
[Musik]
sie rollt den teig aus perfekt können
wir bekannte ich bei diesen grünen
kugeln nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und dann kommt die böse könig die
zubereitung sollte nicht so schwer sein
man sieht schneewittchen wie sie an den
teig ausrollen und ihnen als deckel für
ihren stachel werden kuchen benutzt dann
schneidet sie den rand ab und den
benutzt sie dann als schrift für den
kuchen ach ja und die vögel machen dann
doch noch so musste rein und o mein gott
in der video beschreibung habe ich mein
musicali und snapshot ich finde mit
meinem kostüm sollte ich mich jetzt aber
auch ein bisschen prinzessin haffter
verhalten schneewittchen hat ja so
bewegen denn die sind alle so ich fühle
mich dass michael printz
küsten tot jetzt hat irgend so ein
prinzessinnen fetisch
noch 1 5 und jetzt ist alles geklärt wir
können unseren zubereitung machen
manchmal sagt man verschreiben wollte
auf tic tac warum ich so eine herrliche
stimme hat und jetzt wo alles geklärt
ist kümmern wir uns um die zubereitung
also natürlich könnt ihr mich für euren
nächsten kindergeburtstag buchen da
schreibt einfach hier meiner managerin
und dann machen wir da was aus ich bin
ein bisschen teuer klar aber dafür auch
gut und jetzt lege man mir eine
küchenschürze auf wo ist mein fröhlichen
[Musik]
man ganz schön großer vogel
[Gelächter]
ok dann gibt es jetzt los wie man eine
mischung aus 150 gramm vollkornmehl und
150 gramm mehl
und das verrühren wir dann miteinander
dann nehmen wir unsere butter und messen
200 gramm ab ich hab so vermisst einfach
im stehen zu kochen ohne unterlage alles
ein bisschen kompliziert das eigentlich
sein muss und die schneiden wir dann
auch einfach wieder so städten oppenrod
diesem bruder löffel in gips einfach
dazu einfach rein und weil es sich
einfach mehr nachbacken anfühlt wenn man
irgendwo rein macht machen genommen ein
rein mit einer hand
beim zucker mache ich überhaupt keine
angaben das einfach einfach rein da so
ein bisschen was was euer blutzucker
aushalten kann und bevor jetzt mit euren
ekligen fingern da reingeht händewaschen
[Musik]
wenn wir schon beim thema schneewittchen
seit dieser film ist
1937 haus gekommen im letzten geschmeckt
habe ich gesagt bekam in den 50 jahren
raus war auch wieder einfach als ganzes
verkaufen
1937 das sind 80 bis 4 84 ich dachte
nicht mehr dass man profil ich dachte
vor 84 jahren dass leute auf kutschen
noch fahren
der teig muss jetzt kurz im kühlschrank
damit dann bisher ein fest werden kann
sich alle zutaten gut miteinander
verbinden hörten nicht auf was ich sage
sondern sehen uns gleich zum ausrollen
wieder ich bin da schneewittchen dass
das erste tier was mir helfen möchte
möchtest du mir beim kuchenbacken helfen
ja
[Musik]
wenn wir unsere kunden vom vorbereiten
und zwar werden butter einstreichen
damals hatte ich noch nicht wie
schmeckt's money und ich muss es in
einer normalen backform machen leute
100 folgen wie schmeckt später kann ich
mir auch eine prüfung leisten und jetzt
wollen wir mal den teils aus und setzen
wir alles zusammen
habe ich ein kleines vögelchen was die
kamera halten kann ist
mir drauf sagen wir mal so kurz durch
trecker sehr knapp gerade gute reflexe
auch für butter jetzt mal eben noch die
form
ich wünschte
150 abholen
[Musik]
doch toll
heftete eine hälfte brauchen ja von den
decken lässt sich ganz toll aus
[Musik]
die putzfrau sich nicht scheut sich
nicht
was hast du denn da für ein teil der aus
wir jeden tag in der bar ist
ein bisschen wenig trinkt wird
wahrscheinlich am ende zu wenig sein ha
ha
ha ha oder
jetzt kurz hoffen aber dass ein bisschen
angepackt
komm jetzt unsere staffel werden drauf
wir haben sie gerade noch mal ein
bisschen abgetrocknet dass sie nicht
ganz so nass sind aber sind gefroren
deswegen ja
in der ein szene sieht man dass der auf
jeden fall ordentlich gefüllt ist mit
stachelbeeren
[Musik]
ich stelle mir gerade noch mal die
schnelle angekommen wird hinten sagt
auch wirklich ich mach starterin sagt
moderator des so viel besser an jan eben
gerade schon eine probiert und hat
gesagt sie sind sehr sehr sauer deswegen
müssen wir zucker darauf machen weil
sonst ne
[Musik]
guckt nicht so komisch wenn man selber
backt sieht man erstmal wie die zugabe
drauf ist und so das problem ist nur ich
glaube ich doch zu wenig weiß ich ob ich
im video schon damals gesagt dass ich zu
wenig zeit aber ich glaube ich hatte
schon damals zu wenig aber das ist auch
alles auseinander gebrochen
hey
ich
kann jetzt leider diese frau mich
hochleben das abschneiden weil ich schon
so ein bisschen an gebacken habe ich
schneidet das aber man vorher so tolle
szene wie sieht das abschneidet das
gefällt mir hier überhaupt nicht wie das
hier aussieht
[Gelächter]
und das was wieder die vögel mit dem
kunden gemacht haben mache ich wieder
mit einer gabel
wir haben gerade lange darüber
philosophiert was das für ein teig wohl
sein muss weil im film wirkt es sowieso
ein hefeteig der den ball ist man kann
ihn an einer stelle ziehen und der reiz
nicht auseinander so ein tag ist aber
einfach den kannst du nicht so
verarbeiten werde ist halt einfach sehr
fragil und deswegen stechen wird einfach
ein herz aus und legen dann das herz
obendrauf das wird auch ganz toll
aussehen
dieser tag ist so fragil erinnert mich
an eine sache
geschäft brauchen dieses motto ledig
in der zwischenzeit kuchen im ofen ist
werde ich schon mal in die küche putzen
[Musik]
na da werden sich die zwerge aber freuen
und nun stellen wir uns die
allerwichtigste frage wie schnell
heiß
jetzt müssen wir nur noch darauf warten
dass der kuchen abkühlt und dann können
wir ihn auch schon probieren
[Applaus]
wer ist an der tür
kommen sie doch rein kommen sie doch
rein
ja ich habe stachelbeeren kuchen gemacht
braucht ein kind wieso machst du
fühlst dich werden besser schmecken
ich habe aber leider nur hier ganz viele
äpfeln
ganz besondere
kam der infa wünsche erfüllen so sein
wunsch ab
na da würde ich glatt mal abbeißen
[Musik]
wie wirken
also
ist das
sonst gar nicht aufstehen
sogar
privat denn darauf war das größte waren
aber auch absolute
hammer
- verlassen jetzt wo mein prinz mich
wach geküsst hat können wir jetzt den
kuchen probieren er sieht wirklich sehr
schön aus ich bin immer noch nicht ganz
zufrieden mit dem teig ich glaube es
gibt einfach ein besseres rezept aber
nichtsdestotrotz sieht sehr schön aus er
riecht wunderbar also stachelbeere
riecht auch sehr sehr gut und jetzt
schneiden wir den namen und probieren
mal
geworden keine katastrophe leute ihr
wisst was jetzt kommt und nun stellen
wir uns wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt der stachel werden
aus schneewittchen
dazu seine
stoffe in bern sind sehr sauer der pike
ist mir nicht knusprig genug also ich
glaube ich müsste noch besseres rezept
herausfinden was wirklich knusprig am
ende wird dass man da so ein bisschen
mehr wie blätterteig denke ich
vielleicht auch einfach nur blätterteig
nehmen sollen oh mein gott aber es wäre
nicht entschieden aber blätterteig sehr
hätte auch wie lange war da jetzt
berufen wie nokia und das war es ich
hoffe euch hat die folge spaß gemacht
ich hoffe ihr habt so einen kleinen
flash tricks bekommen ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich bei den machern dieses
kleides bedanken märchen an tv das ist
ein verein der sich mit märchen
beschäftigt und ich wollten uns ganz
kurz sagen dass ich bei den berliner
märchentagen in 2021 dabei sein werde
und schneewittchen vorlesen werde wir
sehen uns dann doch jedes mal wieder
biss dann antenne ich es jetzt gucken
zum frühstück
[Musik]